our great ally saudi arabia is executing  one person every two days and the number  of beheadings is soaring at least 175  people executed in the past year in  saudi arabia according to a report by  amnesty international the kingdom killed  102 convicted criminals in the first six  months of 2015 alone which puts it on  track to beat its previous record from  1995.  those killed include children under the  age of 18 at the time of the offense and  people suspected of having mental  disabilities nearly half of those killed  were foreign nationals who amnesty  international says are  disproportionately suffering under the  saudi justice system because of two  things number one  xenophobic prejudice in saudi arabia and  also the lack of understanding of the  proceedings in arabic in saudi arabia